always very peaceful substantive and
we covered the whole range of our
regional and international agenda
the deputy of the chief commander of the
united arab emirates
in 2018 said that our
relations are relations of strategic
partnership when the talks at the
highest level moscow were held and last
autumn
during the state visit of president
putin we have
stated our desire
to stick to this course in all the
possible areas of our cooperation
we are doing quite well uh
with the economy never in the first nine
months of this
year the traitor turnover rates for more
than 60
percent and it exceeded two billion
dollars
the inter-governmental committee on the
trade and economical corporation
is working we strengthen our partnership
between the
russian direct investment fund and the
muppa
modabola investment company from uae
our energy departments work closely in
the opec plus group
and in the gas exporters forum all these
matters will be talked about in more
detail
by foreign minister with the deputy head
of the government
and the minister of the trade and
industry
later today
technology area in particular in the
peaceful use of the outer space and
on the december second hour
carrier soyuz has brought to the orbit
the
uh
and we are also developing the
corporation
on uh fighting countering the chronic
virus infection
and the emirates they start the third
phase of the clinical
trials of the toxin uh specific
feedbacks
and we're discussing the possibility of
manufacturing this vaccine under license
discussed in detail the original and
international agenda first of all
we discussed the situation in the middle
east and the north
africa we have common
or close ideas regarding the majority of
the current
issues and within this perspective we
talked about the syrian settlement the
situation in libya and yemen
and uh regarding the middle eastern
settlement
with the current situation in the
israeli-palestinian
situation and arab israeli situation
and we have also exchanged our views
regarding the reinforcement of security
and the persian gulf area
we have agreed on continuing that
cooperation and coordinating
our reaction in the u.n first of all
regarding the melabilization of
international community
to form the universal the front of
countering that terrorist actions and we
have a number of
ideas that we're going to work on
pays a lot of attention to countering
the terrorists and extremist
ideology countering
the mentality of hatred of any
manifestations of discrimination
and extremism
and overall i think that the talks were
very useful
in regards to promoting our strategic
partnership
and putting a lot of uh
ideas in it
thank you
my friend sergey thank you very much
i'm very grateful for this very warm
welcome it's good to be here and thank
you for saying
such kind words towards my country
we are proud to have such strategic
relations with russia
um
we have seen it very clearly that these
relations are truly special
unique and we are determined to further
promote our relations
going forward
um
and we are also proud to see that
our experts are working groups are
cooperating closely on a number of
tracks
as well as we know that our embassies
are in close contact it's good to see
that the united arab emirates are about
to complete the first
is
also next year i will be hosting the
expo 2020 exhibition
as you know it is 2020 exhibition but
due to the
reasons which are well aware to you it
will be
taking place on the next year i'm sure
that this venue will become
one of the first events of that kind
which would
follow i hope successful completion of
this
pandemic transition
we believe that the whole of the
international community
has applied every necessary effort in
order
to come up with an effective solution
against the covet 19 pandemic
as soon as possible and i hope that
these new solutions that we have in our
hands today
will make us even more robust and will
help us to face
similar challenges in the future
and i once again would like to confirm
mr lavrov that we are proud
we are happy to have such friendly
strategic relations between the united
arab emirates and russia
thank you very much
for ministers that you discussed
security issues
in the region of the gulf so how
well i will start then russia for a long
time
has been raiding the question about uh
normalizing the situation uh
around the gulf many years ago we
suggested to the gulf countries to think
together along with
some outside help about the principle
that
could become the groundwater called the
trust measures
and gradual building
not a long time ago last year last
thought and
we held a meeting of the political
scientists
of the experts with the participation of
representatives of
all the concerned countries where this
concept was discussed and it was
assessed in a positive
we believe that uh under current
conditions keeping in mind the crisis
around a
comprehensive plan of action regarding
the iranian nuclear program
and attempts to replace this plan with
something
else despite the resolution of the
security council of the u.n
the efforts regarding these matters are
becoming
more and more important does
on the number of foreign we discussed
these russian initiatives that the
foreign minister is meeting
of the arab
countries cooperation and myself
we understand all the problems all the
difficulties that exist
among some arab countries
in the region and islamic republic of
iran
and we express our readiness to
facilitate
to help to start the dialogue among the
countries
[Music]
um
foreign
for us this problem
is still not solved and it's a pressing
issue so we would like to finally put an
end to this
we will work hard together with russia
to make that happen
um
and united emirates cooperate closely in
a number of tracks
a number of issues recently i mentioned
that one of the focal points is to fight
terrorism
and extremism
this country has confronted with a
number of challenges
after the government fell
in this country the situation has
spiraled and on top of that
we see that there are still streams of
arms munitions coming into the country
which
is a breeding ground for terrorists that
has undermined the situation
even more uh
libya remains a key country
in this region and together with russia
we are doing our best
to help the situation to stabilize
a good example of our work is
our cooperation our participation in the
berlin conference on libya
we supported the political process in
the country
um
and we will continue cooperating
with our berlin partners and
our partners in the arab league in order
to achieve stabilization as soon as
possible
well we
have uh given our statement
clarifications
in regard with various reports uh
regarding the actions of the russian
federation with regard i believe in
crisis so our position is
well known everyone
all that we do with other
outside actors including our partners
from the united arab emirates
egypt and other states is aimed to
start the negotiations
political process that
would have all the significant
parties of this country all its
historical religions
and important thing that the
participants to these political
approaches were actually had authority
to represent their political groups
represent their
regions and weren't just artificially
selected by some outside party
having these girls in mind since the
very beginning of the libyan crisis we
have stayed in contact with all the
representatives with all the libyan
parties uh trying to encourage them to
start the
olympic and two
stop using military
means to resolve their problems
and we have always promoted this idea
that
any kind of international events
regarding libya must be held with the
participation of libyans and of the
neighboring countries of
libya and we were the ones to insist uh
to have this format chosen for
the berlin conference in general this
year
where initially the organizers they
didn't intend to
invite neither libyans nor their
neighbors
and in the end our common goal is to
restore the statehood in libya
that was uh violated that was
destroyed in violation of international
law in 2011.
initially despite the embargo arms
embargo
maybe our nato counterparts
actively supported extremists and
terrorists
uh trying to use them to overthrow more
marcados
regime and then later they just nato
started aggression against the sovereign
state a u.n member and now we have to
deal with the consequences
until now
um
so in all our efforts of today we
let's remember the roots the reasons
of the current living crisis
thank you very much mr lavrov lately
we've been seeing
more and more cases of currency
normalizing relations with
israel in your opinion can
that be contributed to the stabilization
of the situation
in the gulf region
and we know that iran is
quite concerned with that and if i might
like to
also ask a question in arabic to your
opposite number
my question to the foreign minister of
the united arab emirates lately the gulf
countries
have become quite enthusiastic towards
normalizing relations with qatar
so has any progress been made have any
concessions been made
and what are the requirements on the
part of countries who have been
blocking
that's where we come from and we
share this understanding with the united
arab emirates
the normalization of relations of israel
with the arab countries
so it's picking up speed and in overall
it's a positive thing because
it eliminates age old
contradictions and it builds
tracks of civilized dialogue between
countries
at the same time russia stating
its personal official position regarding
this process we have always underscored
that it shouldn't
put a background
the palestinian problem the problem that
might be resolved
uh based on the resolutions of the u.n
uh that stipulates for the creation
of the palestinian state that will
coexist in peace and safety
with the israeli state
and today mr minister said that
united arab emirates have
the same position
of course international community has to
help to restore the direct
communication channel between uh israel
and palestine
russia on a number of occasions
suggested to
renew the work of the international
quartet that includes apart from us the
united states
the u.n and european union
at the same time for years we have been
saying that the efforts of this quartet
must be
also help the arably countries
to join the court in its efforts
and today we have also talked that
that long ago another accordance was
formed
uh within the arab countries
egypt saudi arabia jordan and united
arab emirates
are part of this reported and i think
and
uh mystery foreign minister shares this
opinion
that we should try to
join the efforts of the international
quartet and the
so that we could discuss the conditions
on restarting direct
israeli-palestinian negotiations
and our final goal ultimate goal is
complete
normalization of the situation in the
region
uh creation establishing of the
palestinian state
and starting of the
relations of israel with all the
countries in this region
which is enshrined in the arab this
initiative that wasn't just
endorsed by the arab
but it was also in trust endorsed by the
organization of islamic corporation uh
if i'm not mistaken it was done
at the tehran summit so going towards
this goal
is our shirt
objectives
um
the coordination of efforts with russia
and i can tell you that
they have been and they will be the
focal point of our agenda
and we do hope that through joint effort
we will
successfully kick start the process
between
palestine and israel
but to do that we need not only to nudge
the two continuity
towards that but also know what the
consequences will be
unfortunately over the last years we
haven't seen any
chances to make that happen um
in that context we need to mention the
positive role the constructive role and
position that russia
has been having towards the issue of
palestine
um
working together with russia and the
international quartet and the arab
league we will succeed in
focusing every effort and we will
show the region and the world that there
is still hope for peaceful settlement of
this issue
we welcome the efforts of kuwait
there is no doubt that
in the situation of today we need to
normalize relations there is
no doubt about that
we believe that a good foundation for
such solidarity
is the positions of the two key states
here saudi arabia
and egypt
certainly we need to make sure that
extremists
have no voice have no place here
in this region
if there are countries who continue to
support
terrorists and extremists then there
will be a problem
and that will be a problem too
of course challenges will remain
more alleged
and to find solutions to the immediate
problems
will of course require a very special
kind of work on our part we will need to
find some
unorthodox approaches to these problems
we see that some actors in the region
these days
seek to promote a civilized approach
trying to be more civilized while others
are
acting quite in the opposite fashion
very important to single out those
countries
who are moving towards a more civilized
approach in their best become more
modern but also to show that there are
others
who have different approaches maybe we
can help them to become more civilized
too
thank you
thank you merry christmas
you